um okay hi again everyone welcome back
to the last talk of today before the
reception so today we'll have another
talk on the lower bounds of metropolitan
sampling
methods for world conditions
distributions and this is by kevin tian
who's a phd student at stanford a
student with aaron sidford so kevin
please
great
hopefully the life works okay um
okay uh yeah thanks everyone for coming
to my talk um so yeah i'm a
grad student at stanford and this is
joint work with gintat lee and rochi
shen who are awesome collaborators from
the university of washington um and the
talk will be about uh lower bounds on
metropolized sampling methods for
well-conditioned distribution so it's
it's a
interesting follow-up to to sinho's talk
okay
so um diving straight into it so a major
research goal of computational sampling
and uh this program i guess in
particular is understanding the oracle
complexity of sampling so here we want
to uh sample from a density whose
negative uh negative log density is
convex and it's in high dimensions so
for large d
okay so this talk is going to focus on
the well-conditioned regime in
particular and i'm going to try to
motivate this a little bit
um
so in particular when i say oracle
complexity usually we assume that we can
interact with the density through some
manner of oracle and a natural one is
derivative orbitals where at a point i
can query
say the value or
the value of some derivatives of the
function
okay and under these kind of oracle axis
it's natural to assume regularity
assumptions on the derivatives of the
function and the wall condition regime
is in some sort in some sense the
minimal sort of assumption you can make
okay this is not quite true but um
hopefully you'll forgive me for this
motivation slide
okay
and uh as cinderella mentioned in his
talk uh sort of the overarching goal
here is to develop an uh analogy analogy
to the oracle complexity of uh
optimization which is quite well
understood in the well condition case
and there are many uh many interesting
connections between sampling and
optimization some formal some informal
um and uh
let let's just say that it's uh it's
been a great success story and
optimization and we'd like to get
something simply uh similar for uh for
the sampling setting
okay so formally the uh the well
conditioned uh regime we're going to
study in this talk
is as follows so the goal is to design a
sampler
to produce a sample within epsilon total
variation distance from the target
distribution pi
and the regularity assumptions we're
going to make on pi
is that um its hessian is point wise
bounded between multiples of the
identity so mu and l so here mu is uh
say larger than zero and l is uh smaller
than infinity and this uh this condition
number kappa which is uh this like l
over mu ratio we're going to see them as
finite so this is what i call the well
conditioned regime
okay and finally we're going to be
working under the following oracle model
where um at a point you can query either
f of x or the gradient of the function
at that point
okay so this is uh sort of like the
setup we're trying to understand the
oracle complexity of this sampling task
great so um diving a little bit into the
types of methods that people study
there's sort of two classical regimes in
the recent literature
one is the low accuracy regime where the
sampler has a polynomial dependence on
this target parameter epsilon
um and it's typically given uh through
guarantees and various distance metrics
including total variation as i described
but also various other ones such as uh
washington distance kl divergence and so
on
and there have been a variety of um
discretization tools and like analyses
and like base dynamics that have been
studied i won't go into it too much but
suffice to say this this uh this regime
is very rich
okay but this this is not the focus of
today's talk
um today's talk is going to focus on the
high accuracy regime where we want to
design samplers with poly logarithmic
dependence on the target accuracy
epsilon
okay so the key difficulty in attaining
such rates is reducing the bias of the
sampler so in particular most of these
like low accuracy regime samplers have a
bias target distribution and to fix this
problem uh typically
we we use metropolis adjusted algorithms
uh to correct for the stationary
distribution so this is like a general
tool that takes any proposal and fixes
it so that the uh the stationary
distribution is correct
okay and finally i'll mention that most
results in the high accuracy regime give
guarantees in total variation distance
and the main high accuracy algorithms
that people study in the literature and
often are these algorithms inspire
what's actually used in practice are the
metropolis-adjusted language algorithm
or mala
and metropolized hmc uh hamiltonian
monte carlo and this talk is going to
focus on giving lower bounds on the
complexity of using mala and
metropolized hmc uh for the sampling
task i mentioned on the previous slide
okay great so when i first tell people
about this results um
it's always like a little bit
disappointing because you know an easy
counter is okay you didn't really see
anything about the complexity of
sampling if you're like uh proving
algorithms specific lower bounds okay so
that's like maybe a little bit sad
um so let's look on the bright side so
on the bright side i i know how to prove
a result so you know that's that's one
upside um maybe a few other upsides are
that i can use this algorithm specific
lower bound from an algorithm design
standpoint to pinpoint uh difficulties
in the algorithms that i have to like
sort of overcome in order to obtain
better dimension dependencies or other
dependencies
um and finally
the candidate hard distributions i
specify for these particular algorithms
uh might have some like nice general
properties that you can exploit in
further lower bound design okay so these
are a few upsides now if it sounds to
you like i'm just making a bunch of
excuses um that's fair and uh
i think a major goal of this field is uh
is to prove like you know algorithm
agnostic lower bounds in high dimension
so let's let's try to do that
okay
okay but uh you know charging forward
because this is the results i know how
to prove um
i'll survey the types of lower bounds
that we give in this work so
the first uh the first pair of results
i'm going to state um so these are
direct copy paste from the from the
paper but let me try to break down what
the statements are
so
first of all these these two theorems
are lower bound against mala so this is
a one parameter family of algorithms
which is specified by just a step size
so basically if i give you oracle access
to a density
then the only thing molly gets to choose
is the step size um so in that sense
it's one parameter
okay and i'm making this distinction
between gaussians and uh
general well-conditioned densities where
a gaussian is required required to have
a constant hessian so namely it's uh
it's
a negative log density is like a
quadratic
okay
um
furthermore i'm fixing the uh the scale
of the problem in these theorem
statements uh where uh where i i
guarantee that not only is the uh the
ratio of the eigenvalues uh bounds kappa
i'm telling you up front it's between
one and kappa so it turns out that this
only makes our uh our life harder in
terms of proving lower bounds and
otherwise the problem is a bit silly
because if you fix a step size first and
then i fix the scale i can sort of like
cheat my scale to make your step size
like absurdly large and then your your
chain sort of can't do anything so this
is a sort of a natural assumption
okay and finally uh theorems one and two
give relaxation time uh lower bounds so
relaxation time is this note is a
spectral notion of mixing in particular
it's defined as the inverse spectral gap
of this transition operator so there's
like a formal definition here but you
can basically think um
it it's a way to measure the rate of
decay of any uh function which is
orthogonal to the stationary
distribution so it's just saying like
how quickly does this like transition
operator kill off orthogonal functions
okay
um so yeah that's sort of like a
breakdown of what these theorems are
really saying
okay so just
yes what is your job here when you said
makes our job harder you mean your job
of proving lower balance proving lower
balance yeah so like why does it make it
harder i'm confused so there's two
different ways i could have stated this
i could have said first you tell me a
step size and then i get to pick a
function right alternatively i could say
first i pick a function like namely a
scale
um
and then you pick a uh
you pick a step size right i'm just
pointing out that the first alternative
is a bit silly because if you pick a
step size first i can cheat the scale to
make it um
like your step size not make sense
isn't the statement picking the step
size first i'm super confused oh i'm
saying i'm fixing this the scale as one
cap
the statement includes the skill
okay so just uh yeah so to address
philippe's question in a cartoon sort of
the thing you should think about is um
nature or like whoever gave us the
problem picks a uh picks both the
dimension and the scale of the problem
like one kappa and then like the bad guy
like the uh the upper bound uh
algorithm gets to pick the parameters
and then we get to pick a hard function
or starting set or whatever to try to
like combat your algorithm
okay
so um recapping a little bit from
sinho's talk i want to like clarify
uh the context of our
lower bounds with the uh the upper
bounds that are known in the literature
so sinho's talk describes the following
picture um if you have a feasible
exponentially warm start so namely like
a star i can just like tell you off uh
right off the bat then the mixing time
of mala is roughly kappa d
okay but if i promise you you have a
polynomially warm start then you can
actually improve this to kappa root d
okay um and here's the definition of
warmness it's sort of like this like
worst case ratio between um starting and
target distributions
okay so
you might stare at these uh these
theorems lower bound theorem statements
a little bit and these upper bound
statements and be like okay what gives
first of all your lower bounds are in
terms of relaxation times and these
upper bounds are in terms of more
classical mixing times okay second of
all your lower bounds said nothing about
the warmness of the starting set right
they were purely like spectral
statements so um how do we you know get
around this
so our third theorem is a mixing time
lower bound for mala so in particular we
say that um you can upgrade theorem two
to say okay um
in fact it takes this many iterations
from a exponentially warm exponentially
small
measure set
to reach constant total variation from
the target
so
i want to like clarify a few things in
this statement
so if i ignore the statement about
warmness and i just read the number of
iterations required to reach constant
total variation distance this is sort of
like the standard combinatorial mixing
time definition um you can imagine like
you're trying to prove some bound on
mixing time of a graph uh it's over like
the worst starting vertex something like
that
okay but in continuous time this is sort
of like
hard to um
hard to accomplish because you can
imagine my starting distribution is just
like you know way out there in space and
sort of like
it'll just take forever to do anything
right
so we give a slightly more refined
notion of the um of a lower bound which
is warmness sensitive so the way you
should think of this is uh first i get
to uh it's it's an infamous
algorithm parameters and then i get to
choose the worst warm start of a given
warmness um and then and then we try to
lower bound this quantity
okay
so i'll mention that this sort of lower
bound while it seems like a little bit
easier to prove because i get to like
literally choose the starting
distribution um it's actually compatible
with most continuous uh mixing time
analyses which only depend on the
starting distribution through this
warmness parameter
so
you know
if you want to like
circum uh like uh like
navigate around this uh this lower bound
you're gonna have to like
you know come up with some new upper
bound machinery so i think this is like
a reasonable uh warmness institute yes
functions um
uh
satisfying the parent i'm just
highlighting that i get to choose the
warm start after you choose the
parameters
so your supreme the second supreme she's
just referred to should be after your
face right
all right
sorry
uh i i i think the comment is just that
like the supreme is actually over more
things like it's also over like the
potential which gets to respond to the
before or after
the supreme court you said you first
picked your steps up yeah sorry yes yes
right good point actually while we are
on this can you mention the harder event
task of i give you a specific
distribution you can prove a lower bound
on uh like is this possible to actually
get similar rates if i actually
allow you to first look at the
distribution force you to use mala and
select your step size after you look at
this yeah that's a good question you're
basically saying like you can pick the
best step size for your particular
distribution or something like that um
yeah i haven't thought too much about
that that i agree is uh important and
perhaps more challenging
likely more challenging
okay
so i have a question oh yes
uh
the
you can always try to match your
uh initial condition so that it's not
too bad or it's very far away from your
soup of peanut butter start i think
that's you're seeing like my
definition doesn't rule out just
literally starting at this uh target
distribution or something like that
right like no no i don't mean you start
with the target distribution because you
don't know that but what you can do is
you try to fill something easier for
example you have you look at the shape
and say some gaussian may be much better
than your
the initial condition that
has still formed right so i i agree this
this this sort of statement doesn't rule
out upper bounds as you're describing
that like take advantage of the fact
that you know i know more about the
warmness of the starting distribution
other than the warmness i'm just
pointing out that if your analysis only
actually depends on the
starting distribution's warmness
then this lower bound rules out your
your analysis but i agree you can take
more advantage of the warmness uh the
warm start than i'm that i'm telling you
okay
okay great
are there any more questions because uh
this is yeah sort of like a key uh
definition
okay
great
so um
our second set of uh results are about
uh hmc uh which is sort of a multi-step
generalization of mala so
we give like
two types of
statements uh
about hmc so the first is an
unconditional spectral lower bound
and it has the following flavor um if
you take k-step hmc
then the relaxation time can only decay
by a factor of roughly k uh up to this
fact that there's a square root d in the
numerator rather than a d
okay so if you've never seen hmc before
basically you should think that each hmc
uh iterate takes k steps of some like uh
integrator like subroutine but the point
is in every iteration iteration of hmc
it requires k gradient queries so
roughly speaking if you uh improve the
mixing time by a factor of k
then you sort of like even down because
you need k gradient queries per
iteration so theorem 4 basically says if
you're willing to ignore um differences
between relaxation time and mixing time
um
sort of there's inherent dimension
dependence in hmc you can't beat this
sort of rooty uh barrier
okay
so we also have like some
mixing time lower bounds for hmc which
are a little bit weaker in the sense
that they only work in certain regimes
of this uh k parameter so the statement
is as follows um for small enough k
so small enough here means like k is
less than some polynomial in d we didn't
try very hard to optimize it but like
think like k is less than d to the 1 10
or so
um you can only decrease the mixing time
of hmc from like theorem 2 or theorem 3
or like molar result by a factor of
roughly k squared so this implies that
the query complexity can improve but it
can only improve by a factor of roughly
k
so
my takeaway from this is if you want to
beat the mixing time of mala by more
than a like like a polynomial factor in
the dimension you have to take
polynomially many steps um that's sort
of like the conceptual message
in these sorts of results
okay
and these are all from exponentially one
starts just like our molar results
okay so just to summarize uh the last
few slides um our first set of results
are on mala and we have kappa root d
uh spectral lower bounds for gaussians
and kappa d mixing time lower bounds for
well condition distributions on the
other hand for hmc we have these sort of
like in uh incomparable results we have
kappa root d over k type lower bounds in
the spectral sense and we have kappa
root d over k squared type results
in the mixing time sense um so it's an
interesting open question to like
improve either of these
okay so for the rest of this talk i'm
gonna first define the the two um
algorithms we're gonna study
then i'm going to sketch the proof of
theorem two this is sort of like our
main like technical result which says um
like the kappa d spectral like uh lower
bound
and i'm going to give us
a proof sketch of theorems three and
four which are like the mixing time
lower bound and the uh the hmc spectral
lower bound and then i'll give some like
parting thoughts on like things i think
would be exciting to work on and um
things are our our paper suggests uh for
practitioners and
lower bound theorists and things like
that
so the first um algorithm we're going to
study is mala so uh sinha already
defined this i'm just going to like rush
through this a little bit um the idea is
it's just going uh it's going to like
apply a filter to the euler
discretization of language dynamics
so the proposal distribution from a
point x is you're just going to advance
for time h
um
by the gradient and then you're going to
like draw a gaussian around it and then
uh the actual algorithm is to just apply
like a metropolis filter on top of this
okay
um yeah i won't say too much about this
other than uh the one parameter is h
like how long you uh discretized
okay
um the second family of algorithms we
study is uh is uh multi-step hmc
so you should think the base um like
continuous time process that's being
discretized here is the hamiltonian
dynamics which are defined here
and uh so the actual like uh discrete
algorithm before the rejection step
is you run k steps where k is some like
parameter i specify from the algorithm
of the following like leapfrog
integrator so from your point you draw a
random velocity you do this business k
times
and then you spit out your final point
um this particular integrator has like a
lot of very nice properties that i'm not
going to like go into too much here but
the main uh thing that you need to know
for this talk is that it's like time
reversible in the sense that if i have
some like starting x
v
and some like
ending x prime v prime um up to signs in
uh the velocity sort of like running it
backwards will give me the same thing as
i started with so uh this nice cancel is
a cancellation in the in the filter and
you end up just getting a ratio of
hamiltonians
uh
don't worry about it too much if you
haven't seen this stuff before
okay
so i'm going to um give a quick outline
of how we're going to prove this molo
spectral lower bound first just to
recall it's it's uh we're gonna say that
uh the relaxation time is roughly kappa
d
okay so the first two steps are um
pretty straightforward the first one is
that we're going to reduce a spectral
lower bound to a step size upper bound
so we're going to say that unless your
step size is like um if your step size
is too small then you can't mix very
quickly in the in the spectral sense
okay the second step is to rule out huge
step sizes so like
there's certain like large ranges of
step sizes that we're not going to be
able to argue too much about um we're
just not going to worry too much about
that so these two steps i'm just going
to outsource the previous work so the
first step um is
basically taking care of in a sinho and
collaborators work where they show that
uh under certain like construction types
of constructions the uh the relaxation
time you should think of as basically
being inverse the step size so small
step size means large relaxation time
okay um and for step two i'm just
basically going to assume that the step
size is at most like one over capital
log d
uh you can just do this from uh the
proof of theorem one the gaussian case
which is just kind of explicit
calculations so i'm gonna gloss over
this
um note that combining these two already
shows a lower uh a relaxation lower
bound of like kappa ish but we really
want to get this d dependence so this is
our starting point
so the next step is to argue that when
our step size is sufficiently small i
can construct the inverse exponentially
sized hard set with the following
properties um
in this rejection probability
calculation the noise is going to
dominate so basically like all the other
stuff is going to be low order compared
to the um the movement induced by the
noise
and then i'm going to argue that from
starting in this uh this hard region
most of my velocities that i sample will
result in rejection so the idea is if i
initialize you at this like hard region
you just can't get out um if the step
size is uh is too large and this will
let me prove an upper bound on the step
size which will let me prove a lower
bound of the relaxation time okay this
is like a high level of how we're going
to attack this problem
cool
so the first step is uh is to argue the
following um we're going to decompose
the proposal distribution into a random
move and a deterministic move so the
random move is just going to sample a
random gaussian vector and add a
multiple of it to our current point and
then the rest is just like deterministic
i advanced by the gradient
okay
so formally the property we're going to
use is that if i decompose this like
negative log acceptance
you can turn it into a a combination of
the results of taking that gaussian step
and a bunch of like relatively low order
terms for the relevant range of my step
size
um
okay
so
you might ask why would you think to do
such a thing
um and in hindsight i think the easiest
example is sinho mentioned in his talk
uh
the upper bound on the metropolized
random walk which actually has the same
dimension dependence as the uh
the uh the smarter mala algorithm uh if
you don't care about condition number
you only care about dimension dependence
so
if you have like a little bit of
experience playing with these like um
discretized landmine diffusions you sort
of have this feeling that like
really the bottleneck to improving the
dimension dependence is this uh is this
random drift term and
in that sense it's like uh it's higher
it's higher order in this calculation
okay
and now the upshot of this uh this above
calculation is that it tensorizes so i
can just like make like a one a hard
one-dimensional distribution and like
copy it a bunch of times
um so this is sort of like the rough
strategy
let's make this a little bit more formal
so what's our goal here we want to show
that like this dominant term of like um
the effects due to the random move
uh is roughly omega of h kappa d
for all the x in my heart set
and most choices of random directions g
right
um
just skipping ahead to the punch line if
i were able to show such a statement
note that if i took h to be like
substantially larger than one over kappa
d
then
this rejection probability is quite
large in other words we're rejecting
almost all the time
so the point is um if i can show this
then uh i basically get the results i
cleanse
okay
so let's decompose this um this first
expression a little bit it turns out you
can basically write it as an average of
these quadratic forms with second
derivative f across this line
so let me interpret this formula for you
a little bit um x sub s is going to be
like a linear interpolation from the
starting point x
to the point you move to after the after
the random move x sub g okay so x sub
zero is going to be like um my starting
point and x sub one is going to be like
my new point sorry for overloading
subscripts
okay so in one dimension if i just think
of this as like uh you know i replace
hessians with second derivatives
everywhere um
sort of if you just stare at this
expression it suggests that if i want to
make it very small
i should just make the second derivative
at the starting point
large
and
quickly decrease it along most random
trajectories and if i have that then
this uh this expression is
is quite small okay this is just by like
the imbalance on where it places the
mass on the second derivatives
okay
so it turns out that like basically the
entire complexity of this is just
showing the expectation of this
one-dimensional quantity is is small
because once i have that i'm just going
to like repeat uh repeat it d times and
then sub gaussian concentration will
take care of most of the rest of it um
there's a little bit of technical care
that needs to be done but that's
the high level difficulty it's just
constructing such a hard one-dimensional
example
okay
so you might already have a guess on
like how we're going to do that um
yeah so basically like we're just going
to make the hard region like these like
every other periods in some cosine based
construction and if i start from within
these cos uh these like upper periods
then most random moves if i pick the
scale of the cosine like well enough
we'll quickly decrease the second
derivative
and
a few lines of like calculus will show
that this um
has the desired expectation property
that we wanted
okay and finally to like tie it all
together the hard set of inverse
exponentially sized uh measure
is going to be all x
where coordinate wise it has large
cosines okay
and um also coordinate wise it's not too
large this is just like control things
like gradient regularity and things like
that
um
and it's not too hard to convince
yourself by staring at this picture that
i can cook up an example where
the uh the measure is roughly two to the
minus d
so
that's basically the construction
okay and now to turn this spectral lower
bound into a mixing time lower bound i
have to do a little bit more work
um
it turns out that our proof strategy
already implies a mixing time lower
bound oh yes
because
i was
distracted
but i i thought the lower bounds were
for what
is how how do these cosine is coming
sorry so formally the hard function is
going to be the sum of a quadratic in
the first coordinate this is to use like
um dilemma from uh
the chewie all paper to say like the
mixing times one over h and then every
other coordinate will be this hard
one-dimensional function
and in expectation
the uh the rejection probability if i
start coordinate-wise in like these
regions
is going to be like h-kappa d-ish
and then you can turn this into a
high-probability bound by like some
sub-gaussian concentration
but okay formally the hard function is
this okay
[Music]
yes this is a this is a log complete
function this is a well conditioned like
um i guess you can see from this
calculation that the second derivative
is bounded between kappa and capital
over three
okay um to turn the spectral lower bound
into a mixing time lower bound we have
to do like a little bit more work so it
turns out that in the large step size
regime theorems one and two basically
already imply mixing time lower bounce
because just recall the flavor of the
argument was that from this set we just
can't leave it right so you know you
can't mix if you can't leave certain
sets this is like the definition of
conductance
um but if the step size is small we need
to argue that it requires many steps to
move a lot
so here it turns out that you can just
kind of like
cheat a little bit in the sense that
theorems one and two have a gap so i can
use my step size lower bound from two
on a instance from one and it'll just be
like totally overkill so let me let me
uh be a little bit more formal about
this
so to show um
a lower bound in the in the small step
size regime we're going to use a target
as a standard the dimensional gaussian
so like normal zero identity
um we're just going to make the starting
set like
x which is kind of like close to the
origin
and we're just going to argue that over
roughly kappa these steps
when the step size is like one over
kappa d
a the chain never rejects so basically
like
um all the proposes pass and b
um
x doesn't move by too much so like
originally it's like point five root d
in radius now it's like point nine for d
and it's not hard to see that like if
you only stay within a ball of point
nine root d you haven't mixed okay and
as i mentioned um to prove that the
chain never rejects we have to use it
the step size is like so overkill for
gaussians that like over the course of
the entire algorithm it basically never
rejects
okay so just to wrap this up
um the full proof of theorem three has
kind of three cases
so to rule out very very large step
sizes we use an explicit gaussian
construction to rule out intermediate
step sizes we use this cosine based
construction
and then to finally tie it all home and
show that um you know very small step
sizes can't be used to obtain fast
mixing we use a gaussian again so yeah
it's kind of interesting to like
maybe remove
all this casework
and come up with one compelling heart
example this is sort of like an artifact
of how we do things
so
um
i guess i have a little bit more time to
talk about our hnc lower bounds
um
i'm going to focus on the spectral lower
bound
and
sort of the first thing you would try if
you uh so okay the leapfrog
discretization is nice in the sense that
uh once you expand out this difference
of hamiltonians you give this like
relatively nice looking expression on
the right um due to many like
to me unexpected cancellations okay and
the first thing you would try is you say
okay this thing in the sum
basically looks like that molar
calculation you showed like like many
slides ago
so why don't i just like repeat the
model argument k times and then you know
trade a k for a k and then get the same
lower bound
um
so unfortunately there's some technical
difficulty in doing this because you're
taking a joint expectation over the
entire sum and we did try this
and you basically it does lead to some
mixing time lower bounds but basically
the the order of decay of k is more like
one over k squared
and this sort of uh
we don't know how to get around this and
we actually think it might be like
interesting to explore this from the
angle of upper bounds
okay
but taking a slightly different approach
for gaussians uh this entire expression
vanishes because
uh well if you remember the calculation
from like a few slides ago it's like
integral of the hessian and the hessian
is a constant so this stuff is all like
zero
okay
so the remaining thing to do is argue
that
there's a certain uh threshold of step
size where
above that step size we can sort of like
cheat a little bit and i'll be like a
little more precise what i mean by this
and then below that step size we're
basically back in the case of mala where
these um these iterates behave a lot
like the mole demolitions and then i can
just apply theorem 1 again
so that's the high level strategy
um a little more formally supposing our
negative log density is a quadratic
the first step we do is we just write
the coefficients of um the hmc iterates
as polynomials in the step size and the
eigenvalues of a
okay so this is like a lot of like uh
messy looking math but the the main
punch line is like like a
we try to
come up with a
characterization of these polynomials of
these coefficients
so that we can kind of trick hmc into
doing something very funny
so
the idea is we want to uh
design a step size
range where
these pks and qks behave in a weird way
we want pk to be like plus minus 1
and qk to be like 0.
so the idea is
no matter what random velocity you
sample along some coordinate if i can
make it so that this is always
zero and this is always like plus minus
one you can't leave any symmetric set in
that coordinate and therefore hmc will
get stuck
and then below that parameter range
we're going to use uh the model analysis
okay so um
yeah so i guess the punch line is that
uh
hmc is actually doing some kind of
funny chebychev polynomial stuff behind
the scenes
so
actually i'm curious uh
if people know like the so when we wrote
the paper i was under the impression
that this connection was maybe not known
before but digging a little bit further
after talking to some people it seems
that some people in numerical analysis
notice that hmcs are hmc leapfrog
iterates are implicitly implementing
some chebyshev polynomial um i want to
like get to the bottom of this uh
uh trans of please talk to me if you
know about this but anyways the point is
we can actually characterize these
polynomials pk and qk explicitly and say
okay
the first coefficient is
related to a chebyshev polynomial of the
first kind and the second coefficient is
related to a chebyshev polynomial of the
second kind and they have these nice
properties that extremal points of the
first kind are zeros of the second kind
so i can exactly get the kind of
behavior i want
um
yeah it's a bit magical to me
but the point is if the step size is too
large i can like plant a hidden
coordinate and make it so that this
extreme behavior happens
and
if the step size is not uh so large then
in these coefficient calculations the
first term dominates and basically i'm
back in the in the muller regime of the
constants
um
there's a little bit of care that needs
to be taken to like make sure the
constant here and the constant here
match up but i won't go into that too
much
okay but this is sort of like the
strategy
cool
um as a few parting thoughts
i want to say
direct open questions of our work
include simplifying our constructions so
many of our constructions are
sort of like multi-layered and we kind
of like do different cases to handle
different regimes um
like at least aesthetically it's
interesting to see if this is
something you can list
um another interesting technical
artifact of our analysis is that our
exponential lower bounds are actually
bottlenecked at two to the d so for
these cosine base constructions like
we kind of rule out warm starts of
measure roughly two to the d uh and this
is like kind of inherent because like
you know cosines
like every other phase is like two right
um
but in fact a recent upper bound we
showed was that you can assume that the
condition number is any uh if you're
only trying to go after rates that scale
linearly in kappa you can show the
condition number is like any any
constant close to one uh that you so
desire so there's actually some like uh
yeah
these these sort of statements are at
odds with each other and it's
interesting to see if we can remove this
to the d barrier yes and so to be clear
this uh the precise question here is
whether you couldn't do these
constructions with two replaced by like
one point
exactly
okay um
yeah from an upper bounds perspective
one direction i'm personally quite
interested in is that the lower bounds
on hmc sort of
are very rigid in the sense that they
assume fixed step sizes and counts for
uh for the agency algorithm but in
practice a lot of like these heuristics
actually uh
try a bunch of candidate step sizes or a
bunch of uh candidate step counts and
then pick one adaptively so it's
interesting to see if uh we can we can
get stronger upper bounds for these
heuristics defying the lower bound
constructions
um also i want to mention that this like
k versus k squared uh gap in proving a
mixing time lower bound for agency uh it
might be real and i i i sort of want to
understand
um
if
we can capture this effect in the upper
bound side
okay
and finally uh on the lower bound side
uh you know
at this at this point uh
we must be sounding like a broken clock
but yeah any any uh
any anything algorithm agnostic in high
dimensions would be super cool
okay um thanks so much for coming to uh
coming to my talk and uh
i wouldn't be doing my uh
my views as a
co-organizer of complexity of sampling
working group if i didn't tell you to
also
stop by and work on some of these
problems
great
thank you kevin um so we have a few
minutes for all questions um do you have
any questions
yes
i
first want to start with a comment as
someone who has uh thought about lower
bounds
i just in defense of your work it is
very hard to derive algorithm
independent lower bounds and anyone who
spends time thinking about it
would realize that very quickly because
it's even difficult to figure out what
is necessary to to generate a sample but
okay so that that part out uh i'm
wondering so
how
far can you push these techniques so so
you know an obvious uh
next thing to try is a lower bound for a
metropolized random walk so so what is
missing to to get that
right so i guess
there is an upper bound of d for
metropolitan walk and our proof is kind
of showing that
d is right so i guess like the
interesting question there would be like
what is the right dependence on kappa
probably
um
that one's pretty yeah that's pretty
interesting i i haven't thought about
that uh it's a good question
yeah our technique kind of like under
the hood is already handling uh the
dependence of random walks
questions
can i ask a question
yes please so uh there are some of these
works trying to establish upper bounds
for hmc by using some um
not a leap frog integrator but something
more sophisticated um so
i mean have you thought about proving
lower bounds for these
yeah it's interesting i think um
so maybe the biggest
mismatch in assumptions is just that
typically using smarter integrators
requires higher uh derivative bounds
i guess
yeah i actually have thought about it a
little bit but not very seriously uh
it'd be interesting at least like under
like the um hessian digits assumption
which has been used to get
uh improved upper bounds under a warm
start
uh if we can show lower bounds
depending on the dimension so yeah i
think there's like there's this
phenomenon that like uh hmc if you
assume more
uh
derivative bounds that you get like
better behavior it'd be interesting to
like understand the skirt if that's kind
of what the question sounds
yeah but i think if i remember correctly
there was this work by entirely and
santosh vanpala that they actually only
assume uh first order derivatives and i
mean with this sort of uh collocation
type of integrators
yeah so that's um that's in the
uh
low accuracy regime so that's that that
has like the inverse quality it's like
not adjusted
yeah exactly it's not metropolis yeah so
i think
i think the statement is like you get w2
guarantees under
uh no dimension dependence but like when
you when you try to convert it you get
some dimensions
okay very good uh thank you kevin and i
think um let's take the conversation
outside so thank you everyone for
attending the first day of the workshop
i will have a reception today and
thank you and see you all again tomorrow
[Applause]